Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Laura Comand
Quando è stata l'ultima volta
che vi siete sentiti vulnerabili?
Be', per me credo che sia
esattamente adesso.
Nel mio lavoro come sarta
e come consulente d'immagine,
mi trovo ad operare con un tessuto
molto complesso e molto prezioso:
l'essere umano.
Per la precisione, mi trovo ad operare
sia con il singolo tessuto individuale
di un essere umano,
sia con il tessuto collettivo
che chiamiamo moda.
E la consulente d'immagine,
a ben guardare,
è un po' l'anti-moda;
perché l'interesse primario
è che una persona si senta bene
nella sua pelle,
al di là di un modello ideale da seguire.
Quindi è una professione, certo,
che ha a che fare con l'immagine;
ma contrariamente a quello
che si potrebbe pensare,
ha più a che fare con il senso di identità
che con l'estetica.
A proposito di identità,
mi ha sempre affascinato il nome stesso
che ci siamo dati come specie:
esseri umani, appunto.
Per le altre specie,
non usiamo nomi di questo tipo.
Non diciamo "essere rosaceo"
per definire una rosa.
Invece per noi come specie
ci siamo dotati di un nome composto,
in cui la parte davvero interessante,
secondo me, sta nell'aggettivo.
Umano, infatti, non è solo
una condizione di nascita,
una qualità naturale;
ma è soprattutto una direzione di scopo,
una qualità in potenza che va sviluppata;
e quindi ci siamo dotati di un nome
che contempla natura e scelta insieme.
E questo è molto interessante,
perché già in pieno Rinascimento
uno come Pico della Mirandola
parlava dell'essere umano
come soggetto che si trova,
in ogni momento,
a decidere se essere un bruto
o un essere celeste.
Per lavoro, mi trovo costantemente
a maneggiare le identità degli altri:
per la precisione,
mi trovo costantemente sullo spartiacque
tra una vecchia identità, magari logora,
e una nuova, o perlomeno un suo desiderio.
In quel momento,
quando le persone arrivano da me fragili,
in una fase di cambiamento, di crisi,
il mio ruolo deve essere
fondamentalmente maieutico,
un po' come lo intendeva Socrate.
Io faccio per loro
da levatrice, da ostetrica.
La mia via è essenzialmente
una via femminile,
perché privilegia il contenimento
alla penetrazione.
Per spiegarmi meglio,
io non faccio come un hacker.
Io non entro nei sistemi.
Io tesso una tela,
e aspetto che sia la stessa persona
a scoprire dentro di sé
aspetti che non aveva considerato,
e poi insieme li portiamo alla luce
e facciamo in modo
di comunicarli all'esterno
con un linguaggio essenzialmente visivo.
Ma l'identità esiste?
Io non ne ho mai vista una che cammina:
quindi ontologicamente
direi di no, non esiste.
Però ci serve come concetto,
in questo mondo,
per sentirci visti, scelti, voluti:
un po' come quando si sceglie un nome
per un bambino che deve nascere.
E come tutti i nomi,
può diventare anche una gabbia
se ci crediamo troppo,
cioè se lo usiamo
come antidoto alla paura.
Ray Kurzweil, grande genio,
grande entusiasta
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
nel suo libro "La singolarità è vicina"
ci parla del fatto
che a breve le intelligenze artificiali
ci permetteranno di superare
la nostra biologicità.
E lui intende questa cosa
della biologicità
come un grosso limite dell'essere umano.
Ma nella mia esperienza quotidiana,
personale, con gli esseri umani
vedo invece che proprio la fragilità
è l'elemento fondamentale
in quei momenti di passaggio.
Perché finalmente cadono le maschere,
e viene fuori qualcosa di autentico
da un essere umano.
E si intravede finalmente quella bellezza
che prima era totalmente nascosta.
Allora, nella grande sfida di Kurzweil
al superamento della biologicità,
ci perderemmo quello che è
il gioiello dell'essere umano,
cioè la sua vulnerabilità.
Non come dato assoluto in sé,
ma per come ti fa pensare, comportare
quel tuo sentirti fragile.
Gli esseri umani sono umani,
e si ricordano di esserlo,
solo quando fanno esperienza -
fisica, proprio - della loro fragilità.
Allora, quando è stata l'ultima volta
che vi siete sentiti vulnerabili?
Ciascuno di noi avrà
la sua risposta personale, intima.
Ecco, quello è stato l'ultimo momento
in cui vi siete sentiti davvero umani,
in cui vi è stata regalata la possibilità
di ripensare a voi stessi
e di darvi, eventualmente,
una nuova direzione.
Oggi va molto di moda Simon Sinek
e il suo "Golden Circle",
quello che dice
che bisogna partire in tutte le cose
domandandosi il perché,
e solo dopo chiedere come, cosa.
Lui intende il perché come credo,
"belief", motivazione profonda.
Bene, io penso
che la nostra vulnerabilità - da "vulnus",
la parola latina che significa ferita -
ci apra direttamente
alla nostra vocazione:
più che "Start with why", come dice Sinek,
ci metterei "Start with wound",
cioè "ricominciamo dalla ferita"
o dal difetto presunto.
Le ferite ci burlano, in un certo senso:
fanno lo sgambetto
alle nostre abilità razionali.
E ci costringono a mettere in campo
risorse che, in un certo senso,
non sapevamo neanche di avere.
Il concetto di vulnerabilità
assomiglia tantissimo
a quello, tutto biologico,
di permeabilità.
Dalle ferite, infatti,
possono sgorgare ideali, emozioni, valori;
ma può anche entrare, inaspettatamente,
il nostro vero progetto di vita,
in una sorta di dialogo osmotico continuo
tra espressione e conoscenza insieme.
Le ferite dell'identità, se vogliamo,
sono le più dolorose,
proprio perché ci fanno tremare
il terreno sotto i piedi:
non sappiamo più chi siamo.
E oggi,
l'esperienza dell'intelligenza artificiale
sta facendo un po' questo a tutti noi,
cioè sta mettendo in dubbio quel primato
che noi credevamo essere nostro
per diritto di evoluzione naturale.
Cioè ci scalzano dal podio
degli esseri più intelligenti del pianeta.
E questo è terribile,
perché mettendo in dubbio
la nostra identità
ci fanno sentire da vicino
l'odore della morte.
Ma allo stesso tempo è bellissimo:
è un momento potenzialmente molto fertile
per noi come specie e come individui.
La retroingegnerizzazione del cervello,
cioè, appunto, l'hackeraggio
del nostro pensiero
per tradurne il funzionamento biologico
in algoritmi, che poi
faranno funzionare i robot,
è paragonabile in tutto e per tutto
ad un nuovo Umanesimo.
Magari non avrà il fascino
della Firenze artistico-letteraria
di Lorenzo il Magnifico,
ma come allora ci permette
di ripensare a noi stessi,
e in sostanza di darci un nuovo nome
e una nuova interpretazione
della nostra identità.
E questa volta abbiamo
il grande privilegio
di poterla reinterpretare
anche facendo tesoro di lezioni
come quella di Stefano Mancuso,
incredibile scienziato,
che nei suoi libri ci ha fatto capire
come esistano al mondo
esseri assolutamente intelligenti,
ma che noi non avevamo mai considerato
davvero intelligenti,
perché diversi da noi.
Magari privi di un elaboratore
centrale, come un cervello;
o magari talmente lenti
nella loro evoluzione
da non poter essere facilmente seguiti
dai nostri strumenti di percezione:
cioè le piante, il mondo vegetale.
E allora, proprio recependo
questo tipo di lezioni
oggi abbiamo la possibilità di darci
una nuova definizione, un nuovo nome
che faccia leva proprio
su quella fragilità biologica
che ha il potere di renderci così belli
e di fare uscire da noi
tutto ciò che è davvero umano,
e che ci accomuna con gli altri esseri.
Qualcosa che suoni come:
"quelli umani tra gli esseri,
con gli altri esseri",
senza più podi o riflettori.
Ecco, siamo un po'
nel momento storico perfetto
per operare un sovvertimento
di prospettiva:
passare, cioè,
dalla intelligenza artificiale
alla saggezza artificiale.
E per ripassare di là,
dobbiamo fare qualcosa
che fino adesso abbiamo
un po' tenuto sotto il tappeto:
dobbiamo ripassare
per quella saggezza naturale
che non avevamo considerato
come una cosa così intelligente,
ma che invece è fondamentale.
In sostanza, ci servono
più esseri umani "integri".
Cioè persone che, oltre all'intelletto,
che è per sua natura
uno strumento di discernimento,
quindi "di taglio" potremo dire,
sappiano anche usare
strumenti di unificazione.
Strumenti che sono da sempre umani,
come per esempio la vita, la vitalità,
la presenza alla vita,
quindi la cura, l'attenzione per la vita,
la coscienza,
cioè la consapevolezza
dei processi che ci circondano
e di noi stessi:
e per finire, la grande rimozione
del ventesimo secolo,
che è il sentire.
Siamo abituati a pensare
che se una cosa la sentiamo
ma non sappiamo spiegarla,
non sappiamo dire il perché,
non esiste.
In un certo senso,
nascere umani non basta più:
serve diventarlo.
"La rosa è senza perché,
fiorisce perché fiorisce;
non bada a sé, e non si cura
di essere guardata":
questa immagine poetica
è di un mistico del 1600
di nome Angelo Silesius.
Ed essenzialmente,
come esseri umani
siamo chiamati a fiorire,
cioè a realizzare
la nostra natura profonda
anche accettando di uscire dal perché,
cioè dalla sfera della razionalità,
della mera utilità.
Con buona pace di Sinek,
la rosa è senza perché.
E non bada a sé,
perché la sua fioritura corrisponde
alla sua vocazione profonda.
E riesce a trascendersi,
in un certo senso, mentre fiorisce,
E non pone attenzione
ai suoi confini attuali, mentre lo fa,
ma si fida del suo fiorire,
magari anche senza capirlo.
E non le importa di essere guardata,
perché appunto il suo fiorire
corrisponde alla sua vocazione profonda
e non ad un obiettivo
indotto dall'esterno.
La grande differenza
tra la rosa, cioè la vita,
e l'intelligenza artificiale,
sta nel fatto che la seconda,
cioè l'intelligenza artificiale,
è fatalmente ingabbiata nella storia.
E per di più, solo nella storia
dell'essere umano.
La realtà è che un parto
della nostra mente
non potrà mai stupirti come un figlio.
Perché è un tuo prodotto,
e non una creatura,
libera e diversa da te
e dall'idea che hai di te stesso.
Chiudo facendo qualcosa che
normalmente non si vede fare ad un TED,
cioè provo a cantare una canzone
che parla di un nome e di un'identità.
Io tengo molto a questa canzone
perché è nata in un momento
che definirei essere quello
di massima fragilità per me,
di massima vulnerabilità umana,
perché quando ho avuto mia figlia,
appena dopo il parto ho sperimentato
alcuni attacchi di panico.
Ecco: in quei momenti, la mente razionale
va completamente in tilt
e tu, semplicemente,
sei convinta che stai per morire.
Poi non succede, ma sei convinta.
E ho scoperto, però,
che proprio il massimo momento
di vulnerabilità
può trasformarsi nel massimo momento
di umanità, e creatività anche.
Allora, in quei momenti
in cui tutto ciò che volevo
era lasciare qualcosa a mia figlia,
è nato un po' quello che io chiamo
il "testamento emotivo"
che io lascio a lei -
che si chiama Celeste -
attraverso il racconto del suo nome.
Oggi vorrei dedicare questa canzone
a tutti noi - fragili, emotivi,
vulnerabili come siamo -
affinché impariamo ad usare
il nostro nome personale come mappa,
quindi non come previsione
di un destino già segnato
ma come strumento di viaggio
in cui la direzione
va costruita giorno per giorno.
E vorrei dedicarlo, anche, all'esperienza
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
affinché ci permetta, come specie,
di lasciare un po' morire
la nostra vecchia identità ormai logora
e di incarnare, davvero,
il nome che già ci siamo dati,
cioè "esseri umani".
(Musica)
Era da tanto, ormai da tanto,
che sentivo uno strano canto.
Io non sapevo, ma la voce cantava,
e qualcosa in me capiva, e ti invitava.
Ma il tuo nome, il tuo nome non mi viene:
vorrei una parola che suoni proprio bene.
Vorrei una parola
che inizi e non finisca,
vorrei un nome
che non ti definisca.
Che fosse per te
una maniera di andare.
Un modo per vivere, una barca nel mare.
Che ti salvi se ti trovi nei guai,
che sia per te la stella
dei marinai.
Di colpo, tutto quello
che cercavo è arrivato;
il tuo nome mi ha riempito
la bocca, e l'ho gridato.
È Celeste il tuo colore;
è Celeste il tuo sapore.
È Celeste anche il tuo odore.
Tu, per me, sei blu nel cuore.
(Musica)
Ma come ho potuto non pensarci prima
È il colore perfetto
che ti avvolge sulla cima.
Quando arrivi, stanco e sudato
e ritrovi tutto quello
che in basso hai lasciato.
È il colore di tutte le Madonne,
di tutte le mamme
che restano anche donne.
È il colore più lontano di tutti:
ma puoi sentirlo
che ti culla tra i flutti.
Che il mondo è sì pazzo,
storto e anche strano;
ma i tuoi piedini sanno andare lontano.
E arrivare in quei posti
dove le cose son vere,
dove la neve è ancora bianca,
e le notti nere.
Di colpo, tutto quello
che cercavo è arrivato;
il tuo nome mi ha riempito
la bocca, e l'ho gridato.
È Celeste il tuo colore;
è Celeste il tuo sapore.
È Celeste anche il tuo odore.
Tu, per me, sei blu nel cuore.
(Musica)
È il colore da vestire
quando vuoi abbracciare,
quello che non sai capire
e puoi solo...
amare.
(Musica)
(Applausi)